[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link
joining us today at the I don't even
want I don't want to say joining us
today at the roundtable Adam delighting
anymore because you said dimmed isn't
that what it is we talked about this
before I'm sorry look all I want I don't
want to say either one of those things
dimly I don't want to say dimmed
lighting because that's wrong I'm just
I'm emitted that right up top wait never
have we've got too much good stuff
written on the sheet of paper that we
just jotted down that we want to talk
about to get sidetracked about stupid
stuff that would we can normally riff on
okay so I'm just gonna say I was wrong
I'm also gonna say not I'm not gonna say
joining us today at the roundtable of
dim lighting because we're here we're
joining each other now you've said it
and we don't need to unexplained that
you've each other we're here we're doing
that he's explained it multiple times
now I'm very happy to be here with you
by my side Rhett oh really
likewise thank ya it's touch and go
these days as will become clear with
your that is with your with your vocal
box yeah let's let's see about that lots
to catch up before we get into the
details of not only my medical situation
which is you know our medical situations
have become sort of a theme of our lives
something about almost turning 40 but
we'll talk about that we want to talk
about what we did today which was very
exciting and and what we amusing and
yeah and then we're gonna talk about a
recent trip to the New York City we got
to catch you up on all of this stuff and
it's in and it's gonna be a roller
coaster ride of retro enactment we're
gonna reenact alert he's ER but first we
do want to let you know very important
those of you who live in New York City
or Los Angeles I live in Los Angeles we
have added two shows one in New York one
in LA to the tour of mythicality matinee
shows on the same days that we already
have New York and LA shows they were
sold out but now if you want to see us
in one of these two places - of
mythicality calm they go and sell Friday
the 11th
of August but if you are a subscriber to
the mythical monthly newsletter which
you can do at mythical monthly comm you
will get very soon probably by the time
you listen to this you'll already have
it a special code and early access code
so you can purchase the tickets early so
that's one of the many things you get
when you are a mythical beast lis
subscriber to the mythical monthly
newsletter is perks of the first Ness
yeah so new shows New York LA they're
gonna sell quickly if the first shows
were any indication so go over to
mythical monthly to sign up for the
newsletter go to tour of mythicality
calm to get tix get the tix don't get
tix nobody wants takes more life here
for that matter carry lots of disease
they keep finding new tix with new
diseases very disheartening really it
really is good on tix though you know
weight of them good for them I don't
believe in I don't I mean my moral
obligation is to humans first well I
didn't say that out of a moral
obligation I just I said it because you
know what they're doing their thing man
they're just doing what they need to do
to survive you got to recognize that
they're working hard at their thing and
it's working but do they really need to
spread disease to a living it to live a
fulfilled life
apparently so I don't know I think
there's some sort of nature mess-up
evident as long as they don't hurt
anybody I'm fine with it they heard a
lot of people good point
I'm not fine with it yeah we should be
anti-tick I hate I hate ticks I know you
gotta be very careful what you're for
and against right I'm nervous right now
I'm nervous now that we're taking a
stance do not take any time you take us
to the end 2017 when we take a stand
about anything you offend somebody we
have offended all tick lovers it's gonna
bite you in the butt yeah
and incidentally I've had members of my
family who've been taken bitten on the
butt
oh man growing up I got died what well
over the person it was a spider but he
did die ya know relative dying got bit
by a spider yeah it wasn't yeah he sat
he sat down on the on the outhouse
toilet and a spider bit him on the butt
and he died from it
a tick was not involved why are we
discussing it are you sure that he died
from the spider bite or just
complications that arose well he didn't
die immediately didn't like yeah he died
from complications of whatever a spider
bite gives him an what year was this
don't fact-check me he was in an
outhouse so it was a long time ago
before your time it's just like a it's a
story that lives in your family my
nanny's side of the family Lucille cuz
one day was I was a kid I was like tell
me about the last words of my relatives
what I just I remember sparking
conversation with my nanny and I said
tell me about the last words of my
relatives a morbid thought from a child
and she said well you had one so-and-so
member of her family who bit by a spider
on the butt in the outhouse and he died
I was like What did he say he's like I
forgot to go you got to go get it
did he really say those no that was a
joke that nanny made it was a joke I
just made up I don't remember what she
told you made that up on the pretty
proud of myself then he didn't laugh
well I was really I was thinking why
don't you laugh it didn't Annie are you
holding back for some reason
ya won't be laughing let's get to that
because I want the people to know why
you didn't laugh at my amazing joke when
you got to go you got to go double
meaning I'm not laughing because I'm
reserving my voice you can probably tell
you can probably tell I psycho listen
and I sound a little bit different
there's not as much resonance in my
voices sad as normal you actually sound
sad I wanted people to know that you're
not sad I'm a sad I'm I am concerned
which we will talk about I don't want
you I don't want you to be overly
concerned but if you remember from last
week we were talking to Steve pink
friend and collaborator director on
buddy system season 2 uh-huh I had to
step out we got to abruptly in the
podcast because I needed to get to my
ENT appointment ear nose and throat it
so I don't know how much of this I
explained before but the long story
short is you know for like the past like
the last month of buddy system I kind of
had on again off again cold like sore
throat
that I just kind of chalked up to
stressed out working too much not
sleeping enough mm-hmm just you know
I've got some cold I can't shake it
because I'm not getting you know rest
and whatever and also your immune system
is weak because you're you're working
right but also in them trying to keep up
with me like three and a half weeks or
so into this sort of mild sore throat
you know we in the last week of shooting
well first of all there's a lot of
yelling I didn't think about the fact
that there's a lot of yelling this
season there was like oh stick your feet
in this bucket and yell open this door
look at this little girl and yell yeah
it's unison I'm gonna tell you right now
no more yelling a buddy system you're
gonna get what happened you're gonna do
like a fine and Replace on every script
rewrite for the word yell and you're
gonna replace the word yell with
whispered you actually thought about
this whisper gently it looks sad from
now on when we have to yell in a
narrative project we're going to get
designated ADR it's going to be somebody
else designated me pinch yell and all
I'm gonna do is just open my mouth well
it's funny because we had that scene
where we open the door and we're
supposed to yell at this girl and we
rehearsed it and we told her because
she's pretty young we didn't want to
frighten her we were like we're gonna
yell in your face really loud but then
when we rehearse it we were like but
first we're going to just act like we're
yelling but no sound is gonna come out
of our throats we actually told her that
before shadow stayed there you should
have stayed there because I was yelling
enough for the both of us and and
coincidentally and still fine I'm great
yeah and I think it based on some
limited reading that I've done limited I
again I so I went to the doctor what I
thought had happened is okay I kind of
kicked myself when I was down like you
got compromised
you know drainage and stuff happen in
your throat and then you strain your
voice by yelling and I kind of like sent
myself into a little bit of a tailspin
and I haven't been able to really rest
my voice and then today we were out with
a team we'll talk about that
and I was taught it was outside there's
a lot of people so I'm talking so now
you can kind of hear that I'm hoarse and
this is what's been happening every day
I've been waking up and feeling fine
like a mild sore throat and then by the
end of the day I feel like my voice is
kind of strange so I went to the doctor
and I went to the doctor right after
last week out to the podcast right
before we left for New York cuz I was
like if I'm gonna have to be on some
kind of like vocal rest or something
like that if there's if there's like a
note or something on my vocal cords if
I've strained them I need to know what
to do so I don't make the problem worse
but and you want things to get better if
things can get better quickly by going
to the doctor before we go on Fallon and
Ryan and Kelly you'd like to actually be
able to talk when we go on these shows
right and I went to the doctor what what
happened well it's a very it was an odd
doctor's appointment I've told you this
but I would tell you this now but I
wasn't listening so I tell me just
listen this time that so I had to go
about an hour away from from here in
order to get an appointment because it
was so last-minute which I will point
out that if I did listen I could tell
the story and then you could save your
voice hmm too late for that
mm-hmm and so I had to drive an hour ago
to this doctor and I I kind of noticed
that the girl behind the counter who was
kind of checking me in but also another
girl we were acting a little strange
when I checked in and in like a cult
know like and this is it sounds
pretentious in because because this has
happened a few times now now that it is
not uncommon for us for one of us to be
recognized when we're in public because
of people seeing the show are unending
sometimes someone looks at you funny or
says something in a weird way and just
because we are selfish self-absorbed
people we tend to think oh she must know
who I am and then there are some times
where it turns out that is true and
other times it's like oh no she doesn't
have any idea who I am
that was a self-centered thing to think
because I'm the egomaniac
you know just like everybody is well I'm
not I think that when when it happens it
happens enough that it turns out that
people have recognized me I know what
that look looks like and I recognize it
but sometimes you're mistaken
sometimes you're mistaken yes but I
don't think that makes me an ego maniac
well we're I'm just saying we're all ego
maniacs Rob I know I know I'm just
trying to get out of the bucket with you
so but you're you're hedging but they
don't you felt the same way about this
receptionist yet but it was weird
because they weren't really really
looking me in the eye
and it was just a little strange I was
like what's going on and then another
once you thought maybe she recognizes me
that I didn't say anything then another
woman comes out and she's like an older
woman who is like in a pantsuit great
she looks like some kind of like she's
like the office manager or something
like that she's not one of the nurses
she's not in scrubs she says and that's
why you said pantsuit you're not you
didn't say something you weren't being
sexist no cuz she had on a pantsuit
instead of scrubs yeah and she and she's
like Rhett and I had just gotten my
paperwork I wasn't even gone through
Rhett please come on back so I go back
there and she's and she's like well the
girls in the back are really excited and
so I'm like oh okay they do know who I
am and now I'm a little feel a little
awkward right because when am I supposed
to say oh and I said something like
great so for a second you weren't an
egomaniac but then you said great and
you became one again yeah I mean one I'm
just trying to play it down because I
I'm not looking it is odd yeah I'm not
looking for special treatment you know I
just I want I want normal woman medical
tree right and so then I girls in the
back were pretty white pretty excited
that's what I don't know what they
thought I was gonna do I mean I'm just
there to have my throat look at so I go
and sit down in it yeah what do you say
exam room I said great so I sit down an
exam room and then she's like one of our
nurses or you know what who who comes in
before the doctor is that a nurse that's
a mystery to me so about 10 minutes
later knock on the door I'm done with my
paperwork a girl young girl 25 years old
comes in and she looks at me and she's
got this kind of smile on her face and
her face is getting a little bit of red
a little bit red and she she just like
smiled I mean I kind of smiled back to
her and then she sits down at the
computer where she's gonna like take her
notes for my like pre-interview before
the daughter comes in and she's like I'm
so nervous and she gets up and walks out
that's all she said all she said she
said I'm so nervous
and then she walked out I was like well
I'm sitting here thinking I just you
know me and we'll talk about this I'm
I'm a hypochondriac I've talked about it
before but yeah yeah I may be concerned
going in here I you know I I go through
okay I've got throat cancer I've got
thyroid Kent you know it's all I got
I think I've got everything and I've got
some kind of throat thing and I'm gonna
have to be you have beyond vocal rest
for weeks and it's gonna change our fall
and I'm worried worried if nothing
concerned yeah
and so she's not helping by saying I'm
nervous and just walking out giggling
and so then I wait like 15 minutes oh
and then she comes back in with the
doctor so she couldn't even come in by
herself so she's got to come back in
with the doctor she still got the same
smile on her face and well yet it's
flattering but it's just not it's not a
good time but at this point something
interesting happened because I could
tell that the doctor as is not unusual
has no idea who I am
but knows that his girls know who I am
and are excited about me being there and
so there was a it wasn't there was an
interesting dynamic there because you
could tell I mean wha since it did he
walk in with a he kind of had wack he
kind of had a little bit of like who's
this big shot I'm the kind of attitude
but you know I'm saying and so and then
I so he says got this vibe from him yeah
I did cuz then I said cuz I he's like
okay what's going on and I said well you
know I've been I've been working a lot
this summer bit on doing 12-hour days on
set you know and he was like twelve hour
days welcome to the club
oh he's he's yeah yeah he's asserting
his power yeah and of course I'm just
sitting marking his territory yeah yeah
he didn't peel all I thought he might
for a second but he did not urinate on
me or her or any instruments which is it
they do teach that in medical school
yeah thank you that's please you gotta
break it out I gotta whip it out no no
no if you're you can either sterilize
your instruments with an autoclave or
you can urinate upon it yeah that's
right oh my goodness so he was he was
basically you just saw the psychology
written all over his face because
especially when he says that right but I
could have been reading some things and
he's like putting you in your place me
but he was very professional very nice
guy but then they it got a little bit
embarrassing from that point because I
first of all I was thrown off my game
with the dynamics of what was happening
but what I wanted was I wanted that
throat scope thing that you had done
when we went to the plastic surgeon's
office not not that we're getting
plastic surgery we made a commercial for
a plastic surgeon in Newport Beach years
ago and and just to get the lay of the
land
you got you throat we found out that he
had a scope that gets in down in and get
video footage of your vocal cords right
while you talked and not knowing what
that entailed I was like let's do it and
he was like it was like no let's do it
yeah and then he numbed my throat and
shoved the camera all the way down in
there and it's in that the making making
of a plastic surgeon well that's what I
was still on Archie that's what I wanted
done if you want to see my vocal cords
move and you wanted this yeah but what
he did he was like okay open your mouth
say you were convinced that you had a
node or something nasty on your on your
vocal cords this is I've never had this
particular situation and so you want
some confirmation you want confirmation
that yeah you don't have the worst case
scenario in that moment so what he does
is he looks at the back of my throat and
he's like mmm yeah you gotta let you got
inflammation drainage she got
inflammation from drainage and then
welcome to the club then he takes his
his little mirror you know like a
dentist mirror like you can stick in and
see different parts of the mouth he's
like say ah and then he sticks that
mirror back into the back of my throat
so we can see down my throat so not
using the scope but using the mirror and
I have a crazy gag reflex so like he
gets he gets it close to the back and I
try going and it's embarrassing because
I've got this fan in the grave the room
fan club you know the rest of the fan
club is generally not at the door
choking like an idiot
and I'm like sorry I got a bag gag
reflex he said okay just breathe like
this who's it gonna be breathing like a
pregnant woman and then he goes him
another power play by the way and has no
medical right he's just doing this for
fun
but he got a couple of seconds before I
just choked him right out of my mouth
again and he was like yep just this
inflamed and here's what we're gonna do
I'm gonna prescribe for medications oh
wow it's like I'm gonna give you an
antibiotic I'm gonna give you an oral
steroid I'm gonna give a nasal steroid
and I'm gonna give you like mucinex
basically like a so but you were
thinking I want the scope I want
definitive I want I wanna I want a
diagnosis or a clean prognosis yeah I
want something definitive I don't want
just like a little gagging mirror action
because first of all a lot of medication
I'm very much anti anti biotics I don't
like antibiotics unless I have an
infection so I delayed probiotic yeah
and I guess so i delayed the start of
the antibiotics until things didn't get
better and I was like cuz he was like
because I could kind of feel like again
this could be where my hypochondriac
comes in but I can like feel like some
chest tightness and like well I kind of
feel like maybe it's moving into my
lungs like I start you know and I don't
know what that's in my head if it's
psychosomatic or if it's legitimate like
oh I'm just gonna turn into bronchitis I
should take the antibiotic I never take
antibiotics it's okay to do it once I'll
do a probiotic at the same time I'm
doing an antibiotic which I have been
doing are you saying this stuff out loud
to Jessie because oh yeah I talked to
her about all the time
and and then I also delayed the steroid
because it's like makes you susceptible
to infection but then yesterday I
started the steroid long story short
I've now basically done all four
medications that he has prescribed and I
feel exactly the same like well that's
because all of them were just to express
his dominance over to the rest of his
laughs no I don't want to you're not
gonna get anybody in trouble I think he
he he did what he usually does when he
sees somebody who's in my condition it
was a little more swag it knocks it out
but unfortunately I still have something
going on with the throat so I feel fine
I don't feel sick don't have like
swollen lymph nodes or a headache or
whatever basically wake up every morning
and I feel fine you're talking to
yourself right now by the way and then I
and then I self talk to make himself
feel better no I don't feel good and I'm
saying this whereas I talked throughout
the day and if it's a day like today
where there's a lot of talking by the
end of the day you can I I feel like I
sound a little bit hoarse just a little
bit hoarse I'm also talking a little
softer because if I talk at a high level
you know there's this like kind of sharp
pain that then makes it feel like my
voice is about to crack and so you know
I open let me let me look just open but
breathe like free yeah yeah yeah and
then you know the better hold your hold
your arms like I'm not gonna do that
like like a puppy dog you're just trying
to embarrass me okay
so and of course I get a deal our
assistant she's got a word you know
she's got to worry about all this
medical stuff too if she's made multiple
thought proctology appointments for us
and she calls the doctor and then the
doctor I'm like okay well he's got a
office over the hill he's gonna office
way up north and it's like well he's got
one type of scope at one place so I'm
basically I need a follow-up appointment
because we got a lot of things coming up
as you know we got a pretty big fall we
got some things that we're money involve
you speaking my voice is kind of an
important part of this whole thing and
so I'm I'm also I'm thinking worst case
scenario I'm like oh I've got I've got a
nodule I've got something wrong as we're
clear that your looks have nothing to do
with it then I'm on board yeah hmm my
looks have nothing to do it what
anything it's just your voice then I'm
cool with this what about your looks
that's pretty important okay it's all
important it's it all works together
didn't I didn't know that's how it
worked
I thought the older ladies like me and
the younger ladies looks likes you and I
thought that we were good that was my
understand all you got to do is be able
to talk man so focus on don't lose that
yeah so I'm I'm worried I'm worried
about I'm worried about our plans and so
you know you like start reading it's
like well you're gonna have this think
vocal fold thing that requires a month
of vocal rest and maybe surgery and all
this and my gosh all this stuff we've
got planned and then stress you know I
think a lot of this is stress induced
I'm making it worse so anyway I'm making
it worse I actually died away to do it I
don't know what to do to help you suck
light up you can't help me I mean I'm
going back to the doctor no matter the
doctor on Tuesday next week and I'm
going to the office where he's got the
thing that is like a different doctor no
no same time all same doctor the one
you've been talking trash about this
whole time you're going back to him yeah
IIIi think he's a good doc what's his
name I'm not gonna say that oh why not
and because he's gay because he's gonna
use the need his scope he's gonna use
the proper scope to get in there and get
the scope you see that happened that's
what's happening you're okay man and so
I'm going to that appointment and then
hopefully what he's gonna say is uh it's
gonna go away on its own and then worst
case scenario is he's like worst case
scenario is like you're gonna die I
don't think that's gonna happen he
probably wouldn't say gonna die and it's
gonna stunt you starting in the throat
but really worst case scenario I think
is like okay you need to let your voice
rest for X amount of days in order for
this condition to go away because you
really haven't let it rest and then the
question is well how long do you have to
let it rest and what does that do about
when gene
comes back etc etc well duh you know
that's where I stood that's what I
started thinking about just don't don't
bring me into it okay you're making me
nervous now is all I'm saying
you're making me nervous okay well I
don't want you to be nervous
everything's gonna be okay I don't be
fine I know I'm gonna be fine
direct correlation with ever how much he
reads and how bad he feels I'm just
gonna put it that way
oh yeah I mean I definitely make it
worse
I said III don't want to be great I
manifest it but I do believe that like
with the back problems that I've had I
do believe that there's a big part of it
that I've manifested the problems so I
do think that is possible for me to
manifest some sort of throat thing
because my back's good now and so then
I'm like oh I gotta find something else
to go roar let's hope that's right but I
think something immediately that is
gonna make you feel better is changing
the subject to the wonderful experience
we had today yes and in New York City
and also showing some love to our
sponsors yes let's do that now okay you
soldiers ourself
yeah you saw on Fallon if you saw that
segment that we we introduced the new
logo for GMM for witness from the show
comes back well that means
yeah just rest your voice man okay yeah
once you do this whole thing I just hold
things because this might be your life
for a few months let's just practice it
don't make me nervous it means that our
old I'm gonna call this the classic good
mythical morning logo which appears on
beanies t-shirts and hoodies available
at our we call it at
rhettandlink.com/store
I don't know what we're calling our
store anymore the beauty is that we're
calling all types of things we're
working on the store and in so many
things figuring out what we're gonna
call it that is currently the address
button link comm slash store that
address will always work but we will
come up with a catchy ER name at some
point you can get the classic good
mythical morning logo collector's item
guys while they last they're at our
stood you say 40% off I didn't even say
four
percent off because I thought there was
another value in the scarcity but now a
court had to chime in
yeah you know I'm sorry you're gonna
have to get to a place you can cover all
the details without me I got it I got
this forty percent off I was gonna say
that forty percent off until what it's
gone and then what happens after it's
gone
too bad it's gone forever I said that
earlier okay good I wasn't listening
because I'm not sharing or holding
things yeah just just breathe through
your vocal cords without without
actually making noise don't speak for
the rest of this podcast I don't know if
you can tell by the like shimmer is
residual shimmer on our faces that we
spent the day at an amusement park or by
just the natural glow of amusement which
is coming from our face if you're if
you're watching this so even if you're
just listening to it can you can you
hear residual sound waves of amusement
from spinning a day at the amusement
park there probably can't but especially
because we may not be exhuming those I
think let lets let's analyze what is it
tell me 100 degrees out there we went to
Six Flags over well I think there is one
in Jordan explained to Six Flags in
sanik Mountain met Santa Clarita where
it's approximately 10 degrees warmer
than it is here so it was a hundred and
one degrees we took the whole team which
now requires a full-size bus did you see
that bus we were in Hey look check that
bus out yeah my eyes were open when I
got in the bus I saw it like a goddess I
did I actually said out loud this is
what this has become mythical
entertainment requires a big old bus
that's nothing to be proud of
yeah and then you start to feel a little
ego man I was like that doctor's office
thing I think yeah I think that's your
real problem you need to be seeing a
different kind of doctor I'm still
reading that book ego is the enemy I
need to read it more I guess so we get
there with the team in tow because we
came back we didn't have not as many
people came back I don't know if heat
strokes happen or
some people drove in cars did we leave
some people I think and it was wearing
jeans yeah though I think she and Ben
they went back a different way yeah I
was thinking I knew it was gonna be hot
out there cuz I've been to Santa Clarita
before and it was literally a hundred
and ten degrees I'm like man we're going
there and I looked on that is it gonna
be crowded is it packed it wasn't 110
today and it was in 100 100 100 and so
like I started thinking what am I gonna
wear
I gotta wear shorts oh my gosh I gotta
wear I gotta weigh the right kind of
shoes I gotta wear I gotta pack a pack I
noticed that you asked me about my pack
I was like well I put a lot of thought
in my pack well what was in it a big
water bottle with ice and water and ice
in it had like a straw it was one of the
it was the biggest one we got I was like
I might bring a second I didn't I was
like I gotta stay hydrated you know me
and you know I gotta stay hydrated
keep that voice going but they had what
I mean they had water at the park also I
mean you either have to purchase it or
you get it from water fountains which I
knew I would still have to go to the
water fountain but I would fill up a
container cuz you here's what happens
you get the whole thing is a survival
situation it's 100 degrees out there it
felt post-apocalyptic man it's like
there weren't that many people and it
was just like reptilian rollercoasters
everywhere and people serving hot dogs
and then just lifeless people crawling
from thing to thing it wasn't that bad
it's like a deserted wasteland of
amusement and you get yourself in a line
brother don't get thirsty in a line
because no one's gonna turn out in oh
here sir have a hydrating beverage no
you're on your own until you get off of
this ride which but there are many
places the but to get water
know when you're in a line man you could
be in a line for four hours but but I
got a bottle of water and there's also
pain reliever in my pack okay okay when
I when I'm still dehydrated for some
reason and I get
headache there's lip balm which of
course gotta have that not only
manufacturer but I keep them a person at
all times to keep the lips hydrated
that's an important part yeah
I think a person I believe you but
you've become dependent on it but I
don't mind because we sell it
I had sunglasses I had I wore contacts
because if I take mice I don't want to
have to switch between glasses in
sunglasses when I go from like an indoor
line to an outdoor rollercoaster so I'm
wearing I wore contacts and then I wore
get transition lenses man sunglasses
I think there's safety concerns with
those because in the moment of
transition which turns out to be a
couple of minutes I think no I think I
think it's like 30 seconds in seconds 30
seconds you run into a lot of wall in 30
second you looks so kind of we're all
out of looks so cool for 30 seconds when
you walk in it's like that dude where's
the sunglasses in sorry they don't no no
wait wait wait no what he well
transitional you walk into a freaking
like dark place and you have to freeze
there until it transitions it's like you
walk in and stand and collect yourself
collect yourself I think it's grateful a
piling up behind you're trying to get
into the establishment you're just
trying to see let me tell you right I
mean you won't be sorry I need glasses
they will be transition lenses because
I've thought about this quite a bit
oh you think you've thought about this
more than me I had I had contact lenses
I had sunglasses I had another pair of
sunglasses that were also not
prescription in case the first
sunglasses I was wearing proved to be
uncomfortable halfway through the day I
had my prescription sunglasses did they
prove to be uncomfortable because
sometimes the way they sit on my face it
hurts certain places where they sit if I
don't wear them every day these glasses
which I don't wear that often are very
comfortable these are my night glasses I
wear these when I go home because if I
wear my day glasses which are the
glasses that I'm known for at night by
the time I get home they start to push
in certain places that I need new
glasses that push in different places so
when I get home I put on my night
glasses which I wear right now because
it's night and I packed these to go with
me today in case I needed to abandon the
contact lenses because
would be uncomfortable so I packed these
glasses and then I also packed my
prescription sunglasses so in my pack
now I see why you needed a pack I had I
don't have a non prescription sunglasses
I didn't realize that crazy this was I
didn't had it out a third pair of
prescription sunglasses a pair of
prescription glasses and then you and
Stevie at one point put your glasses in
my pack do you when you were asking me
can I put my classes in your pack before
we go on this roller coaster you notice
I got kind of stressed yeah it was very
worried because that would be six pairs
of glasses in my pack and I didn't know
if my pack could take it I didn't know
what would happen to all those glasses
now that I see the level of I'm very
familiar with you thought about bringing
a hoodie here that would have been it in
a probably literally thought for a
second yes I get cold my industry even
if it's a hundred degrees sometimes in
the shade didn't get kind of chilly
now I didn't I we haven't I've known
this about you for a long time we've
talked about it you have a different
sensitivity level to these things lots
of differences between me and you one of
the differences I didn't pack a pack for
you is right I had to give a you know I
think I'm thankful that you brought a
pack
I used your pack you did I was like your
dad I put well I use your pack for one
ride I put my hat even though I
specifically said you know what I can
just leave my hat out on the shelf and
this TV was like your hat may get stolen
okay I'll put it in Lynx pack along with
Stevie's cowboy oh yeah right she had
her big Stetson in there we got big got
bent a little bit cuz I took it out and
gave it to Rose a little bit but I just
don't have the I don't have those
sensitivity so I don't need the pack I
felt like I was enter in a survival
situation and I was and I made it
because of the pack I'm just you made it
because I'm just a little bit would you
had it worried for you when you are in
an actual post-apocalyptic survival
situation because you were at Six Flags
not over Georgia Santa Clarita
it was actually I mean all my needs were
met I appreciate you meeting the need of
putting my hat and your in your bag but
the moment I was very hydrated because
what I would do is when I saw a place
that was selling water which
okay you saved money you bought one save
money you supported it an industry of
bottled water which is that's neglige
but I just got a big thing of water and
up during the whole thing I was fully
hydrated I peed multiple times today I
sweated a lot you know mark my territory
around six legs over Jewish I literally
peed twice all day and I drank
constantly not to beat three times I
don't know how I did it he sweated it
out but I didn't know tits that at the
beginning no didn't notice I didn't
notice when we were getting on that bus
but before we left the studio that you
said you turned to me saw my pack and
you said you have a pack I was
interested what you might have in there
and then I said other people have packs
and then you dropped it which is good we
learned not to push each other's buttons
when we're having a fun day so you're to
be commended for for stepping back from
the button but I'm just I was in
generally interested you have a pack I'm
like well what's in a pack I can see it
in your eyes I'm a judgment I think yeah
but that doesn't matter I could be I
could be judging the fact you have a
pack but I'm at I'm also just asking
what's in your pack and so you can
choose to be defensive or you can just
choose to be like well I've got seven
pairs of glasses four levels of pH of
different waters four different points
of the day but it almost put a hoody in
there but there's a windbreak I felt
like the read the may reason we do the
main reason we do your biscuits I think
has become very clear right now this is
a safe place for habit for having a
discussion that if we if we had the
exact same starting point that of this
discussion on that bus at that moment it
would have ended in a fight not in
entertainment but it would I would have
no no but if you're not saying it may be
my fault you know I would have never
meant for it to be a fight I just wanted
to be a conversation no you didn't you
judged me for having a pack and I would
have been defensive and if you judge me
for having something I would be like I
give you the spout the reason off yeah
you would spout it and we found me
that's about the reason off it's about
it and I'm just saying if I if you felt
like not aggressive if I if you feel
like I'm judging you by asking you a
question
just about the reason off I'd be like
okay cool seven pairs of glasses I get
it right but here in the you know and
the auspices of the dim lighting we can
safely have an entertaining conversation
but you but just you yourself just
that's what you're talking that and so
you shouldn't as you describe your own
it's free consideration you recognize
the ridiculous nature of it's like you
recognize and father me though I'm
thinking anything wrong with your throat
it I took advantage of the fact that you
had a backpack which is nothing wrong
with your throat well that's just false
okay I know I know it's false I was
pushing a button but I'm saying you knew
that you would be ridiculous about
having hypochondria having extreme
thoughts jump into extreme conclusions
about what you might have you yeah in
this environment
you were saying you know what it's
entertaining because it's a bit
ridiculous yeah and I'm doing the same
we can do that here that's that's the
beauty of this is a safe space this is a
safe space for us to be ourselves and
not take ourselves too seriously but but
in the front of that bus we could have
had one of those things where the driver
had to back away slowly and I mean
without them but that would have been
ridiculous it wouldn't you do recognize
that would have been ridiculous but your
fault yes yes I'm making fun of us if we
that the fight we didn't have I'm making
fun of that fight we didn't even have
well let's talk about the fun that we
did have at the amusement park begin
week we signed it up did you have fun
because like I know you're so tall and
well I was telling I was regularly
regaling some stories of my past and the
way that I think about rollercoasters
and one of the things the main thing
that I'm thinking about when I get on a
roller coaster is am I going to fit on
this roller coaster it like because
there's there's a there's like seven
different points of contact that could
brewing a roller coaster ride for me the
main to being me I don't have enough
legroom so my well now the throat is one
well yeah well tell us you explain that
in a second but oh
I was just joking nobody hears ya that
was an additional thing I was thinking
about are my legs going to be jammed
into the car in front of me in a way
that makes it uncomfortable and like
makes me think that my femurs going to
snap
we had g-forces get applied no and then
the second thing is if it's a roller
coaster that has a shoulder restraint
they build the shoulder restraints for
normal-sized people within a certain
range and I'm outside of the normal
range and so typically a shoulder
restraint goes you have no business
getting on a roller coaster shoulder
restraint goes down and then like is
parallel to your the front side of your
body
but anyway it's like wearing a it's
worth wearing a onesie this is the same
reason you can't wear one but the
shoulder restraints come over me and
then they're at like a 45 because they
don't completely so I don't feel safe in
my and then if I go too far like if I
pull down too far and it locks into
place it crunches now I'm crime hunched
and now I'm beginning to think about my
back because while my back is doing good
right now historically I've got all
these disc issues with my back you know
and so now I'm thinking oh now I'm in a
compromised situation and I can't get my
neck back and I'm gonna be thinking
basically I'm just thinking I'm not
having any fun yet you ran headlong into
it right because I you know for the team
what I thought about it today is I enjoy
doing things with people like that like
I would never just be like one of those
guys that like amusement park is open
I'm by myself I can ride any
rollercoaster I would just go to the
restaurants and eat go see the shows
that's what I did I saw a great ship
it's ugh a great show you guys were
there that's a great show today you
drugged Cody and Jacob to a show it Six
Flags a place known for nothing but
rollercoasters quark quark the show and
the gear works theater check it out I
don't want to hear about it so acrobatic
trampolines there's a girl on roller
skates was it man conditioned very air
conditioned that was a main reason I've
been there but I would just stared at
the event but I'm not but I just don't
did the the being and fear in that
moment it's like I I used to enjoy
rollercoasters when I was smaller
because there was this like oh there's
no chance than anything's gonna go wrong
and I'm comfortable and I'm just living
on I'm gay I'm living on the edge but
I'm totally safe there's like it's kinda
like watching a horror movie like you're
really scared and you're with friends
but then you know you're safe
the same sensation that's why I loved it
but then I just got so big and then I
started having these physical problems
went back and stuff and now I just go
I'm just I'm this there for the other
people but today the third thing that
I've never thought about was I can't
yell because of my voice oh so I
literally just like just help my mouth
open in a screaming posture without
making any noise the whole time is it
that is good it wasn't as good I like I
like to see on it you got a screw head
much rather prefer to scream on the way
there
Lizzie leaned over in the bus and showed
me a video on her freaking phone of this
recent mishap as a I guess it I don't
know if it was the one at the Ohio State
Fair but yeah fireball the fireball and
then a whole section of I don't know why
I washed it good person died I think I
told her show it to me but I don't know
why the words came out of my mouth
because I never would have wanted to see
it and then it was a iPhone video of the
thing flailing about and then sending a
whole section of it as a projectile and
somebody died does a State Fair though
that's not State Fair I think they set
it up they take it down if they move on
they don't get dental work right yeah
that's what happened it's a carnie joke
I laugh if I could laugh right that's a
br it you open your mouth more so we can
aid and cross your eyes a little bit
okay why did you cross your eyes a
little bit because that's what you don't
do that that made us that makes it that
makes it
I always cross my eyes my left its
unconvincing always cross my eyes well
it's not I'm not convinced by it don't
do it but but do the other part did you
have fun an ADR that but you ADR that
you were concerned but but do you forget
about that when you take it apart I'm a
compartmental a I'm a compartmental list
like Mentalist like someone who can
control their brain yeah right and I can
compartmentalize
you see what I did there I combined two
things into one and I did that make
sense
I'm a compartmentalised maybe in your
own brain I can I have a that's my
superpower I can forget all the word on
the street was specifically what was
said about you
we were like where's Lincoln been and
then somebody was like Lincoln Benner
going hard that was really that was the
specific terminology used for you guys
Eddie was them Eddie seemed to know
everything about the place and right
when we got there he was like we should
go to the the twister colossal or what's
it called yossel something colossal
twister so I was like oh you're the guy
I'm gonna follow you're the leader now
which is incidentally that roller
coaster featured in national lampoon's
vacation originally when they go this is
the updated version when they go to
Walley world Feldman told me this too
you wanna know you're the new version no
the old version the old version which
Chevy Chase it's more intense no I'm
saying the new Verte the roller coaster
has been updated but while the world is
Six Flags so be it when they pull up to
Walley world in the movie is the place
we went today
cool you've never seen a movie have you
know yeah well 98% of you who have seen
the movie recognize that's pretty cool I
know they only made it to the parking
lot and it was closed no boy they were
like no they get in and he uses a pistol
to force his way out to all the right
sounds like a funny movie yeah it's very
funny I should see it so I was following
Eddie Ben was there Mike and Alex were
there and then they disappeared like I
literally haven't seen him since and
Ellie
it was Ellie Annie and Nicky you and Ben
weren't going hard not any harder than
the rest of the people in our part but
that was I mean we just got on
rollercoasters I know but one after
another and I was concerned I got on the
first one it was it was rather intense
the colossal yeah you go through it and
then on the sudden you're on your you're
going through it again like it's like
riding the same roller coaster twice
don't know how they did it but I found
myself doing it and went so I thought it
was over and then I was like whoa we're
going around again on a parallel track
that's a different color
we're doing basically the same thing
pretty cool unless you're ready to get
off and at that point I literally said
to myself silently focus on your
breathing because I want you don't want
to get a headache headache prevention
yeah you might get dehydrated and if a
brain is shaking and panicking abut I'm
already a little dehydrated
and I was mostly concerned about getting
headache but you're not thinking like
you're not scared that you're getting
you know have irrational fears lillico
it's not like I had just watched a video
of people who literally died on a musing
partner well I mean cuz well I wrote the
different Colorado rollercoaster with
Lizzie and she had irrational fears
about dying on the roller coaster that's
why that's why I avoided her the rest of
the day yeah because she has a knack for
but then at the end she was like
compartmentalizing my fears this is fine
that's what she was saying as her sir
that's how she she knows no compartments
how she was enjoying this roller coaster
it was like she was freaking out as we
were getting on she was like this is a
mistake this is a mistake and then she
was like this is fine
this is I never heard anybody enjoy a
roller coaster she wasn't going like woo
this is like this is fine this is okay
yeah she was talking to herself and I
was on the other side of the park going
hard I focused on my breathing in order
to not get a headache and then I somehow
still got a headache I think I was
dehydrated right you have enough water
I don't know pack it's constantly drink
extra water I think I'm addicted to
water I think my body there are worse
things needs too much of it it's it's
spoiled but then I'm constantly giving
it water but then we were that we
finished up the day by riding along with
Stevie we rode the was that called Tatsu
Tatsu Tatsu which unlike anything I've
ever experienced before this is like
what was horizontal hang a hanging down
it's like dangling roller coasters it's
like if you remember like the big bad
wolf from Busch Gardens ain't you got an
ankle dangle but you're safe you know
thing and your your ankles are dangling
but you kind of noticed it's like your
shins are like locked in and then
there's like very like a soft sort of
chest plate kind of thing and this it
all makes sense because right before the
thing takes off it
you forward into a flying position and
at that point I got very concerned
because that's when I started thinking
about safety you know and what I think
is a rational fear because I'm like okay
it's one thing to have like g-forces
push you down into a seat which is like
a part of the track you know part of the
whole thing but when all your weight is
being put on a restraint that just
moments ago was open yeah so I know you
know it open it does open it is possible
to open so what so if it did open now I
would just I plop out well and so then
the plop would take a long time because
we were it's the high it is the highest
longest and fastest not flying the
roller coaster in the nation in the
world it's like if you were in your
bedroom and then somebody picked up the
house and turn it on its side and you
you fell out of your bedroom into the
front door which was closed and then
you're soaring through the air like
rocketing away from Earth to some other
land and you know that that door opens
all the time I go in and out of that
door all the time and let's say that the
door opens out is this analogy working
no nope but I know what you were trying
to say like if you're leaning on a front
door which I usually open out this is a
great analogy but you don't really have
to make an analogy when you have the
actual object that's in the story
already like literally we're in a roller
coaster that has a restraint that could
open anytime we don't really have to
have an analogy we could just explain
how freaked out we were because I I what
makes you think I don't agree I was
super freaked out and I noticed it was
we were in a flying motion and my hair
was a lot longer than normal but still I
I cut it but it's still longer yeah and
so the first thing I noticed is when we
started flying it all just covered my
there's always straight down right that
may be a good thing I couldn't see
anything and my arms were locked in I
couldn't I didn't want to you didn't
want to touch your hair because that's
not gonna save you right but the whole
time I was doing tough for you not to
touch it because I started think even in
a life-or-death situation
start thinking things like I weigh a lot
compared to normal people you know if
anything if any one of these different
stores is gonna it's gonna be mine right
well I never thought about any of that I
was like what this is a crazy cool
experience it was a great ride focus on
my breathing so I don't get a headache
but then Morgan was writing this with us
in Stevie
and he said he was white-knuckle in that
thing the whole time cuz he said if it
did hinge open he was he was dead set on
dangling there were there his arms as as
long as it took but as fast as we were
going you know on a wing and a prayer
brother
I mean how quickly would they if that
one of those things opened I wonder how
quickly the roller coaster would stop
somebody would have to see it maybe
there's like a sensor that sends a
message back I don't know well I don't
like to think our sound guy Ben was
telling me this run we got to the park
another thing I had to compartmentalize
rich our sound guy on some stuff number
yeah number thing well he used to what
he said I used to work at Six Flags and
one day we came in early and we were
running one of the coasters and when it
launched off of the thing and landed in
the parking lot and paralyzed a security
guard the whole roller coaster one of
the cars from the roller coaster did
this and it hit the freaking guy who was
just in the parking lot
yeah and Ben told Eddie and Eddie who
grew up around here it was like yeah I
remember seeing that on the news ramiz
was there I'm not saying it was Rich's
fault
it happens that's the thing is that
these things fail rides fail and
someone's gonna be on them when they
fail and it's like you it's a it's a you
know the chances that you're in a wreck
on the way to the amusement park are way
higher than something happening to you
while you're on one of the ride so if
you just analyze the statistics well I
really have nothing to fear but you
can't
I was only fearing a heatstroke or
dehydration and I and it felt like
enough of a survival situation that it
sounds like we neither of us were amused
I mean I I I left thinking my lucky
stars that I made it out of their life
yeah I don't have a headache and I'm
like well my back still
feels good and you know my knees didn't
like my femurs didn't break I had a
little bit of a headache a little bit
but I wasn't really thirsty so it's cool
it's cool to spend the day somewhere and
then be able to say at the end of it you
know I'm not that thirsty you know it's
like oh yeah it must have had a good
time I'm not really thirsty I don't care
how long it takes we got to give him the
New York City yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what I was going to move into so yeah we
just we got back from a week
Oh eight days in New York City you know
we had we had the the Fallon appearance
and the riot and Kelly appearance was
turned out to be the Kelly and Andy
appearance and yeah Stan you meet Ryan
Seacrest and then we yeah I was looking
forward to that but then by Ryan you're
gonna have to come to us it was a great
getting in maybe we'll go back on but
but we and then we tacked a handful of
days we brought we brought the whole
crowd so we had the wives and the
children and all the children may yes so
nine of us
I kept threatening things like we're not
gonna bring you if you don't have a
better attitude or if you don't blah
blah blah you know you hang there they
all do new world unity they all did
holla I'm saying before we went and none
of them had ever been in New York City
and I we wanted we've been in New York
City quite a bit but we're always there
for such a short period of time that we
you know we haven't done a lot of the
touristy things you know Empire State
Building Statue of Liberty and etc
Broadway show like you'd never seen a
Broadway show right I don't know I seen
one in the 90s but hasn't seen one since
so we were doing all that and taking the
kids so that they could experience that
for the first time but I mean starting
with Fallon they were really excited to
be there now they they were bummed
because you have to be 16 to be in the
audience yeah something like that so I
mean we might could have Lily in Lot we
might get a snuck him in I might get it
passed for 16 in the improper lighting
Tonight Show lighting right which we
would have been fine with that but you
the other kids would have been upset so
they just stayed in our dressing room we
each had a dressing room and so what we
gave one of them and then we just took
the other one and it being the third
appearance on The Tonight
show.i we were finally it says a lot
that we were comfortable enough to make
an appearance on a show that means a lot
to us because it's the Tonight Show
that's super cool and to be invited back
for a third time is awesome so there's a
lot of pressure that that we put on
ourselves it goes along with that but it
says a lot that we were comfortable
enough to bring our entire entourage
meaning all of our blood immediate blood
relatives to like be running around the
place in 30 rock is a cramped place so
it's not like Oh kids you did you'll
have plenty of room and no one's gonna
notice it's like it's free you know we
had to be pretty confident and like okay
we're going to be comfortable bringing
our kids in this environment like
putting them in this room and do what
you think to give you it like a an idea
I mean all this this building was built
a long time ago and a lot of
entertainment is taking place in this
building but it's so interesting cuz
you've got like you know you've got the
Tonight Show on one floor then you go up
another floor and you've got Seth Meyers
you go up another floor and you've got
SNL like it's all happening right there
together but and I don't know if the
I've got the facts right on that but
basically that's how it
what floors on what what's on five or
but the the really interesting thing
feels kind of like an office building
it's your backs like it's a small
hallway and then everybody has like
their dressing room and we were just
very you know because even here in our
space in Burbank it's like it's like
open and there's like a skylight cuz
we're just you know we're not in a tall
office building but it's like there it's
like it was built for efficiency a long
time ago so it's all but and then I
wasn't gonna go through this hallway and
boom you're in the room you're on the
set you're and there's the audience it's
just like how did this it's all very
nice room fit in here like the whole set
crazy but one of the things I did notice
is people a few of you commented on some
of videos and I saw this on social media
as well like oh you guys are it's at
tonight's show for the third time in in
a year you guys must be close personal
friends with Jimmy now he's bringing you
back yeah which is true I mean it's cool
it's like it's nice to now be friends
with Jimmy to like
like so but before it's like that
morning we get up and it's like hey guys
you want to come play handball yes like
yeah I've never played handball is it
like racquetball but just with your hand
right I didn't know until we showed up
at Jimmy's personal handball court right
in his apartment which is crazy awesome
and all we had all we needed were hands
he had the balls and then he was like
later cracking jokes later so funny if
you guys want to come back later after
the show we can do he says usually third
time guests sleep over time yes don't
bring the kids don't bring the wives
right so the segment back is a little
bit awkward but we our hands we had a
sleepover his wife and his kid would
were there but we didn't interact with
him very much we just played more
handball right yeah and by handball at
this point we still mean handball and
what I'm really saying is that this is
all a lie we didn't do any of this I
mean Jimmy is nice enough to cut he
comes backstage but while we're getting
ready and he like says hey guys welcome
back thanks for coming back and we're
like we're so glad to be back this is
awesome yeah don't mint there's no
mention of handball it's just like we're
grateful to be here
yeah and he's very gracious and seems
happy to have us I mean it's their
invitation every time well think about
it
and then we could let this any leaves
and then we come out we do the show and
then this is a guy you don't see him who
hosts a show that has different guests
on it every single night and I'm sure
that he is actual personal close
personal friends and plays handball with
some of the guests that how many how
many people can you play handball right
really and but no so did many hands
answer that question just start with
that how many hands does Jimmy Fallon
have jimmy has been incredibly welcoming
how many does he have he's got two hands
- we got - we got 6:00 p.m. to 6:00 was
singing the 2006 Elvis
but he's incredibly accommodating and
nice and welcoming and it's always great
to see him and we do have a legitimate
conversation and you know when we're not
doing the show but no it's not like he
can't hang he can't just hang out what
people who come on a show that's all I
would ever do and the same goes for us
if you come on our show we can't hang
with you yeah that's true that's true
I'm sorry but like I think the thing
that that I we don't even play handball
I've never played it but we've been the
first time I play it it can't be with
you right I think the thing that I was
thinking was you know there was a
certain level of nervousness the first
time we went on and I don't think any of
this if you go back and watch the clips
or whatever I don't think any of this
really shows but I was very nervous the
first time and in this is nervousness
that is before we come out for I think
for both of us as soon as the as soon as
the curtain opens and we're on the couch
we're not nervous anymore it's the is
the days leading up to it and then the
minutes right before the curtain opens
and they call her name like that's a
very nerve-wracking thing but I was I
say the second time we went on I was
half as nervous and then this time I was
1/3 is nervous it's like decreasing by a
percentage every time well the next time
we're not gonna be zero nervous no will
be if not healthy a fourth as nervous so
it's it's inversely proportional isn't
otic yeah you'll never not be nervous
but my theory is that you go down at a
rate of a fraction of the number of
times you've been there but a function
never touches this asymptote exactly no
there's always gonna be a certain low
level of nervous and there needs to be
but I mean we have that on our own show
but I did the good mornings I didn't
like to think like you know I wasn't
like we ever get back to doing that show
having like diarrhea you know like you
know I think the first time we went on I
probably crapped like three or four
times that day you know you begin to
evacuate everything because your body's
like you're going into battle sucker
evacuate so you can be the light on your
feet
I've right took one crap that day this
time you know I didn't count but I will
next time and so but this time it's like
Jimmy comes back and it's like hey our
kids are here
come in here and we got some photos with
him I even tweeted oh I got a photo and
I tweeted it that's pretty good man for
me pretty good for you link I tweeted a
photo that I took but I was proud man
I'm proud of those children of ours and
wives wives weren't in it because the
Y's weren't in the picture because they
were audience there are over 16 they're
over 18 which is even more important and
they were out there in the audience at
the time that we took the picture with
the felon and then afterward they did it
behind this thing hey can you guys do it
behind the scenes for our channel we're
like absolutely so let's do it with the
kids so like we go in there where the
kids are and if you haven't seen it you
should watch it but the the miraculous
thing is that Lando was in the video I
can't I can't I can barely get him to to
be in a picture in a picture and I said
to take pictures but he doesn't like to
be in pictures
a lot of photographers are like that
yeah he's like Banksy mm-hmm who's not a
photographer no I know what he is but it
is similar I get have to explain that
analogy and get it it's not want you to
see his art like if you're in a Banksy's
house and it was like rocketing off of
Earth to another place yeah don't go
there but I asked I was like hey guys
Lando you want to be in a behind the
scenes video and he sits down and we're
like all sitting you know we're sitting
on the couch and they ask us like
superlatives who would get the award and
like we get the kids to to say which of
us should get certain Awards like most
likely best gift giver and stuff like
that and Lando sitting there the whole
time in the video and I'm thinking I
can't believe this is happening I can't
believe and so then after I was like
Lando I'm super proud of you for being
in the video and he was like I thought
you said do you want to watch a
behind-the-scenes video that explains a
lot
so he said because behind the there's a
TV behind the guy who's feminist there
was a television that showed they while
they were buying while they were
backstage in our dressing room they
could watch the show being film so they
were able to watch it from backstage and
then they thought he was he thought he
was gonna sit down with us and watch by
it was just he was just waiting for
whatever was happening to be over so he
could why I think by the time he got
into it I knew what
happening it was too late he wasn't
gonna show show us but he wasn't gonna
walk out in the middle of the video I
would do that yeah I did and we don't
have to bring up why I did I don't think
you want to relive that you know you can
watch the video so I showed so Jesse was
watching this my wife was watching the
video and she's very self-conscious a
very conscious about Shepards haircut
and how it looked in the video here's
why so if you watch the video because
she's like you didn't fix Shepards hair
I'm like nobody cares he's an
eight-year-old kid but what happens is
if you look at Shepherds hair it looks
like because it is his hair is just like
comb down and just cut straight across
like a hump like a home cut now we paid
for the haircut I'm gonna tell you why
it looks like this so what she likes to
do because she doesn't give this
explanation something that did Jesse
want you to explain this is this called
a show that's gonna make things better
yeah well yeah yeah it is he's not gonna
care she likes us too because of what
happened with the haircut which I'll
explain which is a funny story she likes
me to push it to the side so it looks
somewhat stylish so if you look at that
video it's just like his hair is just
like straight across bangs like cut
straight across his for it has he been
in that room running around no but
here's what happened so we jesse was
taking Barbara to the vet and so she had
Barbara in the car with her and but
Shepherd how to get a haircut and so she
takes Shepherd into the place to get a
haircut and she kind of tells him what
to do and then she's like I'm gonna go
to the car to be with the dog can't
leave a car in the dog in the car or a
car in a dog that would be but bad
unfortunately what that means is that
you've got an eight-year-old who is
Shepherd who you know is very vocal and
he's gonna tell you what he thinks oh
and what he want is now directing the
haircut process oh so what happened is
is while jesse was like combing all down
and cut it straight across she was like
don't cut the front too short that's
what she said because we want to kind of
be able to like swoop it to the side
right but what happened was is the
barber or the stylist I don't know what
kind of place it was basically Shepherd
told Jesse he was like I just kept
telling him
take more off of them take more of the
front because I don't like it to go in
my eyes so somehow Shepherd an 8 year
old was able to convince this well it is
his hair barber so basically just
halfway up his forehead just cut it
straight across and that's that's what
its hair looks like now but it's your
fault for not styling it before the
behind-the-scenes video yeah well she
didn't really care and I said but it's
cute right it just looks like a bad
haircut but it's cute it's only a year
old well it really care but I think the
lesson learned is like people
scrutinizes hair in the comments no
nobody noticed well it's now you know
that I talked about it people will you
know well that that picture that is
bragged about tweeting within 10 minutes
I got people talking about the stain on
Lando shirt and then and then a kind of
mythical beast went so far as to
photoshop the stain off of his shirt I'm
like and then repost the photo without
the stain because enough people were
talking about the stainless sure first
of all it was a it was a water stain it
was no stain at all it was a moist spot
that a seven-year-old and then there
were like people who had kids or
experienced with kids chiming in in the
comment section saying things like
listen there are huge victories going on
here and not even just having him in a
picture or a video which they didn't
even appreciate but just the fact that
you got a kid all in one piece in public
right with a little bit of stain is not
an issue but I'm oh yeah so again this
is the reason why we're you know we're
little calculated about putting our kids
or loved ones on camera because you
can't help but pick apart the the one
thing like there's this great photo and
then you're talking about the stain now
I think most of it was just in good fun
it's like no one was ripping him a new
one because they people just like to
find something that they can put it was
funny that they did and then it was a
funny choice to Photoshop it off I think
that person did it as a way to make fun
of the people who were talking about it
not sincerely I don't think right I
wasn't offended I'm not offended now but
I do think it's a little funny that
there was a whole sub sub thread about
the stain on Lando shirt well speaking
of sub threads
for the Ryan and Kelly Kelly and Ryan
Kelly and Andy appearance you know that
video was of us cooking the steak with
the irons that was posted on the Kelly
and Ryan Facebook page which then Jesse
brought up the comments that the people
who normally had enjoyed Kelly and
Ryan's love it when this happened I
don't know what it is but I love it when
it but you can only imagine what the
average viewer of Kelly and Ryan they
thought we were highly intelligent
thoughtful human beings who know our
culinary experts exactly so they were
there comments like you know essentially
who are these fools why did you have
them on this is not safe they ruined an
iron Oh people it's people eating the
four iron right people who are just not
for iron probably wouldn't enjoy our
content but then Jesse was pointing out
the fact that a good number of mythical
beasts had gone in and then defended us
and she was like and they defended you
in a very thoughtful way it was like
very tactful and they were like these
are I mean people just say something
like you know Dean I have a sense of
humor or whatever but you know you don't
have to you don't have to feel the need
to to defend us but I do appreciate it
when you do but the crowd wasn't
necessarily ready for what we were gonna
do but the crowd in the studio was very
proud to it very responsive in the
moment
well we walked out there for a rehearsal
and they were live morning shows are
just like it's like chaos on camera and
then that everything backstage like
what's happening what's happening what
you know we honor we had like the
cooking thing over to the side like a
side stage but on the main stage the
show wasn't happening they were showing
footage and I think filming the audience
their reactions to it mate my theory is
to get more reactions or just to show
them something while they were waiting
but we come out and the producers like
saying all right we're gonna walk you
through this thing she tells me this cuz
I'm in the front of the line you're
walking behind me and we walk out there
people are watching the show on a screen
in front of the set but then we come out
and like they're people cheering for
and then I turn around and I look at
Rhett and he's got this panicked look on
his face and he says is this it like for
a second you thought we were doing it
well because I knew it was a rehearsal
but we were in front of the whole crowd
it was just strange because we had been
backstage in this kitchen and we like
went through the recipe and knew what we
were gonna do and then you were talking
to the producer and I was kind of like
now I was thinking about your throat I
was a little removed from that no
thankfully at the time I throat felt
fine okay because it was the morning
that's what feels good and but when we
went out there yeah so everybody making
some water everybody was looking at us
and we were very very close to the like
the audience was extremely close to us
like it was very intimate yes and so
they're all looking at us and I'm like I
thought it was a rehearsal but no one
told me it was a rehearsal and now I'm
like we got to do this and then she was
like oh you're not doing this right now
but we did stay out there for 10 minutes
or so like going through what we were
gonna do and this is where we're gonna
stand or whatever never II was just kind
of watching us do it was a little you
walk that you hate I mean it's like if
you're a musician who has to go out into
a soundcheck in front of an audience you
took you can totally relate to this but
and because we've had that experience
too it's like having to do a soundcheck
in front of people I don't have a never
heard I just don't like to do something
I'm not saying halfway before you do it
all the way I don't even like it's right
in front of the people who are gonna see
it all the way and also but you you hate
it more than I do not purposely like
even when like we do like rehearsals on
buddy system I purposely don't like -
yeah hold back act in the way that I'm
gonna act which I found interesting when
we worked with Michael McDonald not the
singer the actor and we were like giving
him some direction in the rehearse and
then after we were walking away and we
started to say something about new his
lawyer is Asian is like I like to hold I
like to hold back on rehearsal I was
like yeah me too me too
and I was like okay sorry I didn't I
didn't mean to try to tell you I didn't
think that's what you were gonna do but
I just wanted to know what and then it
was like I'm gonna stop talking now but
a lot of people have commented on the
picture that Stevie posted to her in her
Instagram
of the three of us uh-huh and people at
least one person was like what is Rhett
thinking with that look on his face
and the thing I'm thinking is that what
what described a look well okay what
were you it's just an uncomfortable it's
just it looks a little constipated and
it's just I'm obviously not comfortable
again I don't like to I don't like to be
in front of people unless I'm actually
in front of them and I'm doing something
where I'm kind of like I kind of know
what my role is and I'm in control like
peace of watching you get a photo taken
for another set of people is weird a
whole audience of people watching me get
a picture taken I that's the look I have
one that's the look I have you can see
that else TVs Instagram maybe we'll put
it in the video as well but that's the
look of a man who's a little
uncomfortable
it's a look of a man who's uncomfortable
because he's posing for a photo while
other people are watching yeah pose yeah
it was a success but yeah I'm you know I
don't know if they if the winner will
have been will have been determined by
the time this podcast goes I don't know
at the time that the but you can like
retweet their tweet about us it goes
through so the way that these things
works is the way that these things may
get people from the internet to come on
their show because people from the
internet can get people to vote for
stuff and like to churn social media
it's all a big game and it's just how it
works so it's like you know you guys are
extremely loyal and you you love to
support us and I'm not and we were very
glad to be there I'm not I'm not I'm not
saying it's a bad thing but I'm saying
that's just how it works
they want to get people churning
comments and votes and stuff like that
it's good for their show he's good for
us is good everybody wins
and it's a choice you're not doing it
out of sense obligation but you're doing
it because it's fun to support us in
their show and if we win then $10,000
will be donated to a charity of our
choice which we've got a number of
charities that we you know we partner
with in the past I don't know if we've
made a decision about which one we're
going to do but it'll be one that we've
you know vetted and I hope that
didn't sound like I didn't care about
the charity I'm just saying that like
let's be real a lot of times the first
thing people think about is not let's
come up with something to give money to
charities let's come up with something
to like churn social media and let's
also benefit charity as another thought
as a separate thought that's a the best
thought but it may not be the first
thought and that's just how things work
it's all about entertainment though man
it's all about entertainment right I
have no clue but then we shifted once we
did those two things we we tried to be
very disciplined to say our channel time
to her the personal time to like that
was fun for the kids they got to be in
the audience for Orion and Kelly and
they made an exception for our family to
let them do that even though there was
an age limit there and that was a cool
experience for them but then we had to
go on the sightseeing tour I think we
went to the top of the Empire State
Building we rode the subways we walked
around I know you love New York City
because you gush about it every time we
go and like the first thing Rhett does
every time he goes we're walking around
he's like look what you're walking her
every time you turn a corner something
else I look down and there's like
there's like metal doors underneath
stuff I just won't go down in there and
look up there it's like people living up
there and their windows you're just it's
just like a kid in a candy shop and a
bull in a china shop together I didn't
break any cheating I didn't break it
well who knows no but I do love it it's
it's it is my favorite city in the world
so the kids experienced that but it
wasn't it isn't I'm not I'm not saying
how do they live there in Los Angeles
but it's my favorite city to visit I
absolutely love it I do love the fact
that it's like it's like walking around
in an exciting gift shop I just love how
every single step you take the writing
there's something else that somebody is
doing
that's just notable it might be
somebody's acting crazy somebody's off
their rocker somebody's having sexual
intercourse in an alleyway I saw
all that you've seriously saw that this
time and I was walking with my son when
it happened but I did not point it out
to him it's like the Wild West or
something what where were you walking
well this is another interesting thing
about this trip is that Locke you know
has moved on from from from diving to
basketball and he's very serious about
basketball and he was very he's trying
out for his school team so he's like
very he was like that I can't have seven
days where I don't play basketball so we
got him a basketball wire out there and
he went to like the public courts like
the street street ball courts on the
Lower East Side which you know it's not
like real street ball there but it was
pretty Street and he went over streets
nearby he went like four times and
played like real pickup basketball would
like real city dudes who were very happy
to welcome them and we actually let him
walk out there by himself a couple of
times like he's I'm gonna go early in
the morning is it okay and I'm like yeah
he's like dad I did like a crime
analysis of this part of the city like
you know you know my son yeah he's like
dad no I'll take that at face value yeah
he's like it's actually much safer here
than it would be in downtown Los Angeles
got only way you really wanted to go so
he had some data yeah but anyway but one
time I went down there with him and then
walked back and that was when I passed
the people having a transaction of some
sort in the alley and you know it took
me a second to figure out what's going
on at first I looked over I was like did
that girl lose something and that guy's
helping her no no no no how far away
could you've thrown a basketball and
broke it up oh yeah I mean I don't know
if I've got that good aim but thirty
yards when I realized they weren't the
right spot they weren't looking for a
lost item they were fine in love I just
scurried on I did a double right I did a
double take because you don't get to see
that every day oh yeah I wasn't daylight
but it was it was down an alley on a
stoop in the alley I'm sorry that I
brought this up and it was it was not a
good scene you know what I'm saying I
died it didn't seem like a romantic
moment it seemed like a it seemed like a
transactional moment
oh and I hid him dwell on it very long I
hadn't thought about it again until you
brought it up I just knew that this is
is now this is the thank you a
compartmentalized my instinct was to
turn to the guy that I'm wouldn't be
like dude check that out but I realized
dude was my 13 year old son I was like
that price shouldn't point that out to
him he doesn't even see that yet so I
told you about it
and I brought it up here yeah and now we
roll the footage for the video of you I
did view though I did video though but I
love the city and I was having the best
time until I was can I say my highlight
worried about my throat the whole time
but I was having the best time other
than that yeah but my highlight well I
mean I think taking being with the
family and seeing these things like we
don't go on sightseeing tours a lot but
like all that we did it food tour one
day ate a lot of food but you saw like
Bob Dylan's house and we first performed
to where Jimi Hendrix first perform
awesome it's like in LA Wow a lot of
food it was that was great but just
experiencing that you you know with my
family and with your family like that I
mean that's that takes the cake that's
the biggest thing but if there's one
like small highlight it was actually we
went to the American Museum of Natural
History right on the edge of Central
Park
Neil deGrasse Tyson's Observatory
planetarium I'm saying it's his but he's
like - mm I don't know he's this guy
he's a public face of it that we saw
like a cool planetarium movie untreated
about that the dark universe I said it
was very moving and then we come right
outside and we go to Shake Shack and get
burgers and shakes and they're just it's
like it's in LA now and I've had it here
and it is amazing but it was just like
to have it there and well we did we
definitively determined that it's both
of our favorite burgers yeah well
everybody everybody everybody likes
something this is the best burger the
Shake Shack has the best burger but I
got burned in my experience
metaphorically
I burnt my mouth on a crinkle-cut frog
the roof of my mouth because I waited a
long time for that mean that burger in
that frying I think it was the fried
that did it when you ate you did a pre
fry you reach in the bag when you had
the bag right when I got it and then I
the roof of my mouth and then I did
something that I learned you should
never do burn the roof of your mouth and
then immediately start sucking down a
shake and I applied vacuum pressure and
the strut that the end of the straw just
so happened to be at the place where I
hadn't yet realized that I had burnt the
roof of my mouth with the crinkle-cut
fry where typically that would be a good
treatment though a cold liquid like that
and maybe that's what I was
instinctively doing but creating the
vacuum to get this thick beverage out of
the straw I'm talking about the
milkshake here it it made the burn
bubble up and it made it hurt bad the
next day it really didn't take full form
to the next day I think it's not just a
burn or the other but I'm I'm eating and
I'm like I'm sucking down the shake and
like every time I'm unknowingly making
the burn worse like I'm making the roof
of my mouth like very tender and very
bubbly like three distinct bubbles where
I was like from one fry from know from
the shake after the one fry you had to
burn then got caught and and just now as
of last night I can I can eat normally
again I mean we're talking five days of
like having eat on the right side of the
roof of my mouth you know how hard it is
to keep food on one side of the roof of
your mouth huh it's real hard I had to
do that man but that doesn't denigrate
the fact that that burger and that and I
it was a vanilla shake I didn't even get
the peanut butter shake you were at
plane well I've gotten the peanut butter
shake here in Glendale at the Glendale
location and it was lacking
I'm being real here huh but the vanilla
like been there and I don't amazing I
don't with shakes it was blister
inducing heaven but the burger was just
so good you know you again and I here's
what I here's what I said because I try
not to eat I eat healthy I did not eat
healthy while we were in New York I'd is
a go whatever I wanted to I think I'm
suffering because of it but I was like
I'm not gonna go back in just each Shake
Shack all the time in Glendale I can't
do that no just go be the communal New
York special but we know it's in
Glendale but I was like we can go there
if we have to the bun the burger which
you know the bun in the burger or the to
the condiments are you know that's up to
you but the thing that the restaurant is
really making a choice for you is the
way they do their bun and they like tuck
it's like a butter too toasted bun and
the burger was just unbelievable we were
literally sitting we're sitting here we
went on this big long trip days days and
days of like sightseeing and we're
sitting here like going on and on about
a burger yeah it's that good and they're
not even paying us yeah but we're gonna
send them a bill here can you do that
can you do an ad for somebody then send
them a bill we're gonna try Shake Shack
you'll be familiar tainment the linkster
at least at least a hundred bucks at
least a hundred bucks yeah triple digits
by hand balls with that kind of money
how much does a hand ball cost well a
good hand bulk or any runya $50 I mean a
good one get to get to hand balls don't
you want for me
well you only need one at a time but if
we lose the backup ball can you lose a
hand ball it's an enclosed room yeah but
if you got a if you got like a drain
without a without a top on it don't have
a handball court with a drain or crack
the door you need a drain because you
need to what you got to spray it down
after a really intense game and then I
can't not talk about the Lion King we'll
talk about it there it is I gotta pay us
as well yeah Lion King Disney this is
getting a bill cuz we talked about how
great the Lion King was I'm sorry for
yelling well we need to like put a
little beep in in in retrospect that
like people will know
mythical beasts will know links about to
yell that beep means I hold the ear
earphones are the earbuds pull them out
ah Thank You b5 compression right leg
meet president it didn't even hurt him
no I'm just trying I'm trying to be
sensitive I don't want I don't want to
turn anybody away because we're getting
that Disney money now The Lion King now
I think we talked a little bit about
this but I didn't talk about it enough I
am I think you and me both us teared up
very early on in the Lion King I can
tear up right now thinking about it I
mean I mean I teared up the opening
vocal was a mate I mean it's like you
got this you got a character which
turned out to be a the baboon a baboon
and I didn't know he didn't know that
until the very end
yeah it's like I didn't I didn't make
any of that singing oh he's incredible
you know what i compartmentalize the
movie of Lion King from this experience
and they were totally separate so I did
I wasn't trying to figure out now it's
been a while since a baboon who holds up
the baby we should have known it because
she held up Simba at the very beginning
but even before that she bust out
singing unbelievable and the voice was
just amazing and there was a guy off to
the side singing - and the two of them
are singing in another language yeah and
it didn't matter what they were saying
but like as the animals come in goodness
it was two giraffes it was yeah it was a
person giraffe well I mean I I think
most people do have some idea of how the
Lion King musical works but like I known
this was not new did you not know that
that's how it was there's gonna be
ladies puppets and stuff I didn't know I
I been talking and I'd seen pictures
I've seen pictures but like when the
Cheetah Girl well you have to explain it
I don't care if people have seen it it's
a it's one person on force on stilts
well that's your giraffe yeah that is
the giraffe but yes they got it the
cheetah
I know which one was the cheetah yeah
yeah I know Mom saying I think the
cheetah had was had long legs and a long
neck I know that's a giraffe no but I'm
saying that the cheetah that all of it
cheated was my fav all of it made me
tear up I teared up multiple times
throughout it when the giraffes walked
out and they were singing a song I
started crying and
then a cheetah comes out and it's the
child-like so great black it's a woman
whose legs are the back legs of a
cheetah and then she's puppeteering the
front legs in her head is connected to
the Cheetahs head and when she moves her
head the cheetahs head moved and it was
like I'm so inventive
I never liked puppets I've been anti
puppet but now you're Pro puppet I'm so
pro puppet now blazing has made you
profile special puppets these aren't
just like no special puppet not pro no
special puppet I'm Pro African savannah
special Lion King I think you're pro
puppet that has a person attached to
puppet that you can see them
puppeteering in a very well they could
have done costume some and it would have
been like Disney on I does that mean
you're in a ventriloquist no yes no no
no no no definitely not because it was
very different
no although they didn't the bird was
very much potential of course it was a
ventriloquist not the burger was my
least favorite
I thought the bird was that one of the
best thing no no I love the birds
character I love what the bird said you
didn't I weren't comfortable
ventriloquist
it was a less creative approach but then
I started thinking what else could you
do with a bird they did what they had to
do yeah I'm also thinking I'm just
thinking they could have been dressed up
as animals but instead they did this
weird thing that's never been done
before when it's like you see the animal
but then you see the person and you can
focus on the person or the animal or the
animal and you make a choice and you can
make you can constantly be choosing to
appreciate the puppeteering or just the
performance of the person right and the
way that they were built I mean it was
like inspiring yeah it was in those
those creative choices of how they they
they said we're not gonna do a costume
and we're not gonna do puppets we're
gonna do both and we're not gonna do
either and it's gonna be something
totally new and it's gonna make people
be pro puppet yeah we've never come pro
puppet so that was a highlight that was
a hug and I was literally tearing up
when it just it was so it was so great
but I will say
I will say in in an effort to to wrap
things up here the next to last day we
were walking on the High Line again
another great experience met some
friends from La out there we're also in
New York and we walked the High Line the
High Line is a it's the railroad that is
suspended kind of nestled whatever the
west side on the the Hudson and they
were bringing like Freight and all this
stuff on the railway which was above
where everyone walked around and now a
living alive stored and turned into like
a place where people can walk like an
like an it's almost like a Nature Park
way that then goes like through the city
and like there's people's apartments and
buildings right up on it super cool
yeah kind of long but yeah I was walking
next to you and you're like well I'm
ready to go home you know in the moment
I said it I knew that it wasn't I
shouldn't have said it to you well
because you know I know I'm on the yeah
we represent very opposite ends of the
spectrum right so I'm doing something
that I know is completely irrational
right is just totally irrational I when
I'm walking on the High Line I'm seeing
these apartments and I'm like I gotta
kind of move here one day like that's
what I'm thinking I'm like we didn't do
that I just wouldn't do like a year when
you're like well how much is one of
those apartments to rent for you we
should just come here for a year just to
spend a year in the city like your
mind's racing a million places you're in
the future I'm thinking of moving there
and then like course you can see that
you daily and and my son is exactly the
same way by the end of the trip he's
going to NYU to play bet yeah yeah
that's how we think we've always been
that way it's like you go into a
situation and then you immediately like
put yourself in it and J and Jesse's the
same way she's like she gladly
participates in that conversation so I'm
like my mind is up here I mean the
future I'm thinking about this I turn to
you and you're like well ready to go
home and I you know I wish I wish I had
the ability to to think a little bit
more out of my circumstances but I think
that by that point in the trip you ready
to go the logistics of everything kind
of started to weigh on me like I I'm
really starting to
how sensitive I am to to space to
personal space in to by this point in
the trip like my fam being in such close
proximity to my family my my kids in the
prompts I mean Lando fell over and skin
is knee and then we're having a mutt
we're having this moment we're like
searching for a band-aid we're trying to
like okay just it's okay just keep it
down you're falling apart here and this
and then the building's start to close
in on me but they weren't actually they
were moving but yeah I recognize that
but you felt that way and then it's just
like you know my own space and hey it's
not about yeah maybe it's a little bit
about comforting about things that we've
explored a lot a lot on this show but it
wasn't just that so it would be an
oversimplification to say well in this
moment I couldn't appreciate where I was
and how amazing it wasn't anything like
that but it was also an accumulation of
many days of another world pressing in
on me and a lot of and having the I mean
having the kids there it does get you
know I was ready to get back yeah I get
you know I could not I would not do well
I'd have to have a serious personality
adjustment to be a stay home man like
that would be a difficult thing for me
to do because just well for me I'm not
putting it on the kids thank you it was
everything it was the environment and
just sheer mass of people like I even it
we asked Lincoln like what do you think
about New York City was like there's a
lot of people and he was like feeling
there's a lot of people really close up
yeah why and I did ask Lincoln this sect
the second night we were walking around
and I what you think about this place
he's like yeah it's not for everybody
that was it that was love but I love to
visit but the kid oh I don't think I
love to visit anywhere too long but the
kids think a this is the kids have you
know you know kids have kid needs
and there are some times you're like man
I've just like if we could just go and
we did this once just go out on a date
but you know he was with our wives and
Stevie and Cassie in that and that was a
great night
but yeah so what you know when I
actually I think about some unrealistic
scenario and I think about being there
I'm like oh this is yeah the kids are
the kids are on their own now the kids
are in college or the kids have their
own careers and we just go and spend a
spin this summer in the city but in
fairness every time I've left to bring
them back to the amusement park for
today every time I've left an amusement
park I've been like I'm ready to go home
and I definitely feel that I definitely
thought it was like man wrangling these
kids and keeping them all happy and like
alive in this survival situation that is
an amusement park boy that really takes
it out of you and then actually they
weren't there today and I kind of felt
the same so I'm like hmm it's a little
bit of a wake-up call right said about
the kids a little bit maybe it's maybe
it's me or maybe it's just the amusement
park but I was very but I did there was
a special feeling that I had when I got
back home and I was like this is
relaxing this is quiet I know there's
mountains there but I can't see it
through the smog that's comforting to
that but yeah I was glad to be back and
I was like I'm glad we live here I'm not
you know I'm not saying I want to live
in New York City we do want to live
everywhere justbe I didn't want to I
want to live wherever I go I put myself
there I'm like I gotta live here but no
one summers in New York City yeah that's
what they always tell you summer
somewhere else yes - huh Wow
thanks for hanging with us as we it's
just a lot of ketchup you know I know I
I like to process what we've been
through so this episode it has felt like
a a scrapbook we just had a scrapbooking
session we journaled we journal I firmly
I scrap booked yeah I didn't same thing
we made memories we cataloged memories
in a way that I would liked you would
like to scrapbook about I would like to
journal about but we didn't and now
there
we have a record a time capsule if you
will of our experience in New York and
at the Music Park and at every doctor's
office we've recorded history that's
what we've done and with a few tweaks
and if we tell the story a few more
times we will have played handball with
Jimmy Fallon that's the beauty of
recording it now because every time you
reacts us a memory you change it yeah
but if we put them with we've got it now
we can't do it actually we actually made
it worse so we could have played
handball with Jimmy Fallon if we
wouldn't have done this we thought we
locked it in well thanks for joining us
I'm gonna I'm going on whether I'm gonna
go out on a limb and say that we'll be
back again next week there's a small
chance that I'm gonna not be able to
speak and you're gonna be talking and
I'll be making motions next week I don't
know maybe it'll happen maybe it won't
that's fine now we'll leave our options
open yeah
tune back in to find out I'll talk at
you next week I can guarantee that
[Music]